you're getting crushed but I'm also very
highly competitive so I'm like I'm
looking for like context clues and the
inflections of his voice I'm just gonna
do this really dry okay are you ready
yeah after Katy Perry which is an artist
that I say I wanted to work with next
hey the weekend B Elton John C Niall
Horan
Niall Horan yeah I'm good whoa yes yes
[Music]
hey I'm Thomas Rhett and this is do you
even know me
what was the name of my first perfume
was it a perilicious
be sent from heaven
or C per
C per
is that it that was it see
um because I grew up with a cat and her
name was Kitty Purry and it's amazing my
fans name themselves my I have this
question my fans name themselves the
Katie cats and so I was I was pretty
much a cat lady for the first 10 years
of my career but now I have transferred
to dog dogs yeah so I was in a band
called High School okay but what were we
called a we were in a band in high
school in high school okay what were we
called a Ron's big teddy bear
B the super purple somethings or C the
high-heeled flip-flops
Ron's big teddy bear wrong
high-heeled flip-flops
why I wouldn't have expected yeah the
high-heeled flip-flops actually if I
think about it that's pretty deep it was
deep yeah we all dyed our hair black and
talked in British accents no you didn't
yeah no way yeah we played one show oh
on Halloween and there were like 20
people that came
reunion tour I would like to see this
again
it was so my dad and his two brothers
were in a band when they were in high
school called the High Hill flip-flops
no but I just wanted to keep the no way
the trim going so maybe my kids will be
in a band called The High flip flops
I do
he leaves pans to soak on the side for
days
B he murders my songs in the shower like
sings them well yeah like he'll or slams
them no no no no like he like sounds
hideous okay gotcha okay see he leaves
floss all around the house
I'm going based off what I would do I'm
gonna go with a
leech pan soaking next to the dishes
soak on the side for days no
no I don't floss enough so that's why I
use the water pick right the water
perfect yeah yeah yeah I couldn't I
should get him that for Christmas then
there won't be any floss you know you've
solved my problems you can probably say
stop marriage stuffer I'm a therapist
that's what I'm here for wow yeah how do
you feel how does it make you feel
vulnerable good okay which of these two
was my first ever tweet in 2009
a Thomas Rhett is going out with my
boots on with dress socks B wow it's
going to be hard to fit my thoughts into
140 characters see
my mom's name is Richard
that's not it because
mom as mum guys we don't say it like
that over here my mom's name is Richard
um I'm gonna go with a because of this
high-heeled flip-flop thing yeah a is
correct yes
what food brand did I recently make a
song for a Starbucks okay B just eat
uh C Bud Light
what was the question what food brand
did I recently make a song for well it's
got to be a because you laughed on B and
Bud Light is not a food so Starbucks
you're wrong what is it it's a delivery
service oh you kind of go okay yeah I
trapped you on that you did trick me
okay
because I want to win you talk about
such fun making that video uh yes I
wanna carry in a hurry
um yeah it's crazy it's weird just like
me I'm gonna watch it great and watch it
all right my cousin and I have a liquor
brand what type of alcohol is it a vodka
BGN seed tequila
I think it's Larry to Carlos it is
sent me some of yours I gotta send you I
did I think so I called my team maybe
you sent it to my manager Virginia
I know you did okay
um
to the nearest million please to the
nearest million okay yes uh is it a 50.1
million
B 90.4 million
C
118.5 million okay
I don't know much about ratings
well but since you were there yeah I
would have to say it was C the 100 Point
whatever million
can you believe this right well because
you think okay I do think highly of you
but I'm going to change B
is it B don't doubt yourself okay see it
is yes there we go it was uh C the most
viewed show that is insanity still but
will definitely be broken by Rihanna and
I hope so well
that's insane the football game itself
was at a pinnacle right here you
remember I don't remember I'm so sorry
excuse me I literally didn't even have
the game on people are yelling at me
like you know who it is Seahawks and the
what
are the Patriots I knew it was the
Seahawks the Patriots
um anyways it was like a crazy time in
the in the game where like there was
some fouls or some calls or whatever the
whole game was turning during the actual
halftime so people were tuning in
obviously to see my show but they were
also tuning in because people online
were going nuts about like how the game
was turning all right you ready close
your eyes oh go yeah what color are my
eyes oh
really oh do I don't get your muzzle
choices I don't need to right no no are
there Brown yes hey what is the score no
no no no okay I don't want you to quit
Midway through okay which animation
series have I not starred in okay
a Rick and Morty
B The Simpsons
see the Smurfs
Simpsons
yeah
which one
Rick and Morty really yeah I feel like
you're down she's gonna tell us I'm
getting crushed you're getting crushed
but I'm also very highly competitive so
I'm like I'm looking for like context
clues and the inflections of his voice
I'm just gonna do this really dry okay
are you ready yeah after Katy Perry
which is an artist that I say I wanted
to work with next hey the weekend be
Elton John C Niall Horan
Niall Horan yeah I'm
whoa yes yes yes yes I just like you
know I feel like such a loser
well try not to lose on this one because
this one's pretty I hope it is easy yeah
we've got one more question okay Thomas
you ready yeah this is I think you can
get there okay okay
what is the name of my micro teacup
poodle
a nugget
B Coco
C Snoop
I'm gonna go with B Coco I love chicken
nuggets so much I actually nuggets okay
okay well it's pretty clear uh who won
pretty clear maybe you should win this
you should read my Wikipedia I should I
should have done that but I really
wanted to come in here as a knot I'm not
Dua Lipa I'm like the 10 year older
version
okay well I know all these things now
good job Katie sorry it's really good
for me good you feel good pretty good
about yourself
we had so much fun
prodding question
that are not fun correct it was awesome
thank you very much this is great great
and my husband this because he's like
this is so weird that we have to be in
bed number he waits until he thinks I'm
asleep and then he throws bunny out of
bed no yeah and I get so mad I'm like
everybody out of bed ah this thing's
bunny has seen yeah well no I shouldn't
see that anyways no no sorry